hey what's up everyone it's Warren and
today we have an official update about
the MCU post Avengers endgame and post
spider-man far from home and this comes
from Kevin Feige the president of Marvel
Studios himself Avengers end game will
officially be the last movie of phase 3
and spider-man far from home will kick
off phase 4 and a lot of people have
been wondering what to expect from phase
4 especially with all of the Fox
characters returning home to Marvel and
Disney well Kevin Feige gives us an
update including an update about the
guardians of the galaxy vol 3 and I'll
talk about all of that in this video
quick reminder about my giveaway if
you'd like to enter for your chance to
win 5 imax tickets all you have to do
subscribe to my channel like this video
and comment down below with your
thoughts and your favorite superhero or
villain the only movie that has been
confirmed by Marvel for phase 4 of the
MCU is of course Spider Man far from
home but we do know of other movies
coming they just have not been
officially announced such as Doctor
Strange to black panther 2 a black widow
movie the Eternals movie and a guardians
of the galaxy vol 3 in an interview with
comic book calm Kevin Feige said that
the plans for the MCU go far into the
future for Marvel Studios but they don't
think they'll be announcing them that
far ahead like they did with the other
phases in the interview Kevin Feige said
I don't think we'll be announcing five
or six years but we know sort of where
we want to head in the next five or six
years in the interview they then went on
to talk about the characters that would
appear in the next phase of the MCU and
although Kevin Feige does know which
characters they have in mind he is not
willing to reveal them yet here's what
Kevin Feige had to say as we've been
doing for years we aren't going to
announce anything post Avengers in-game
or spider-man far from home until post
ingame and spider-man as you know as a
fan there's a tremendous amount of
potential and a tremendous amount of
additional characters and storylines and
groups of characters that were going to
keep playing with and again that's a
testament to Marvel and to the amount of
storylines and characters and amazing
amazing runs that have been in the
Marvel comics so we won't be getting
anything official until after Avengers
end game and after spider-man far from
home and that is because Marvel has a
huge group of characters to work with
and that group just got even bigger with
the x-men in
Fantastic Four which Kevin Feige teased
when he said additional characters and
additional groups of characters and with
all of these Fox characters coming to
the MCU Kevin Feige was asked about
possibly doing three or more movies a
year in which he responded we've always
said there are no mandates to make any
more than two films a year but as we've
seen the last couple of years when it
naturally happens and when there are
ideas and when there are teams ready to
go we're not going to hold something
back and again with the vast amount of
characters that Marvel has and even more
coming from Fox now comic-book comm as
to whether fans should expect standalone
films team ups or all-out ensembles in
which Kevin Feige replied all of the
above so it does seem like there are a
lot of characters coming to phase four
of the MCU which we should find out
about not too long after spider-man far
from home is released and in a different
interview Kevin Feige was asked about
phase four and the cosmic future of the
MCU since James Gunn was supposed to
lead it and no longer works with Marvel
Studios but Kevin Feige said that James
Gunn leading the cosmic future was sort
of blown out of proportion in the
interview he said his influence was
Guardians it was Guardians it was his
input on guardians and the Avengers film
as you've seen an infinity war and on
the Guardians three script which we're
still using so you'll see that influence
I think online sort of the notion of
architect across multiple cosmic things
was slightly blown out of proportion
so Kevin Feige says that the cosmic
future of the MCU will continue even
without James Gunn he was supposed to
direct guardians of the galaxy vol 3 but
they're still doing the movie without
him even though they will be using his
script and the cosmic feature of the MCU
will still be continuing even though
James Gunn is no longer with Marvel so
Marvel has the next five to six years
mapped out including what to do with the
x-men and Fantastic Four when they
return home and it looks like we'll be
finding out some details about phase 4
after the release of spider-man far from
home so let me know what you think about
what Kevin Feige said in these
interviews in the comments down below
and again don't forget to subscribe
comment and like the video so you can
enter the giveaway and stay up to date
on everything relating to marvel and
Avengers endgame as always thank you all
so much for watching we'll forth
[Music]
you